in this video today we will look into
the exact reasons
as to why skull island looked so
different in godzilla vs kong
what really happened to it and what
caused it to be uninhabitable
by the timeline of the events of the
movie the information for this has been
taken from the movie intro credit scenes
a part of the novelization of godzilla
vs kong
and mainly from the comics gbk kingdom
kong which is tied into the cinematic
universe and is a part of the lore
so before we continue on with the video
do remember to hit that subscribe button
to be a part of the mind cue family
so let's get down with this sickness
originally as it has been for hundreds
or maybe even thousands of years
skull island located somewhere in the
middle of the pacific ocean is obscured
from view
by a relentless perpetual huge storm
that prevents anything other than
accidental landings
while it appears to be a tropical
paradise at first sight it is actually
home to many plants and animal species
that are very harmful to human life in
godzilla vs com
the movie however it has been revealed
that before the biodome
that has gone inside it was built the
relentless storms that once protected
the island's life had gradually
begun to overwhelm it wiping out all the
eevee people as well as the rest of the
islands
exotic flora and fauna covering the
entire land in perpetual darkness and
rain
well the story starts with us pesky
humans as usual
monarch discovers something very
peculiar inside the underground cavities
of skull island
brooks a monarch scientist points out
that there is a cave
miles above a vortex that leads to the
hollow earth
as shown on a holographic map of skull
island which they discovered was sealed
in 2012.
the marianas trench and antarctica were
before this
the only known entrances to the hollow
earth and this one was kept as
classified
on skull island a base is built to
research the vortex and its impact on
the island
and there had been quite a lot of
research done up to the point where they
were testing
in order to enter the hollow earth all
that was before the events of king of
the monsters and continued after it and
until present during the
events of kingdom come but during kotm
a super storm appeared in the pacific
ocean like nothing on record
it started after monster zero left
mexico and went there
with wind speeds of over 400 miles per
hour and
air pressure that was so dense it
generates new cyclones every five
minutes
with water spouts reaching the sea floor
the storm had been raging
at the same spot for two years then
suddenly began making its way directly
towards skull island
around the same time dr eileen andrews
had been studying and deciphering some
hieroglyphs
and discovered near the vordex deep
inside the caves which referred to an
eewee legend about a massive storm
and a war with the sun so as he observes
the data on the island
brook's records an audio log he claims
he is missing something because seismic
activity was detected on the island
for a week since the time he was
observing the information
and the storm moved immediately a day
after the seismic activity was detected
on the island brook
believed that the two are intertwined
since then
the earthquakes have become more
frequent and more stronger
and at the same time monarch intensifies
a drilling team inside a cave
that was above the vortex to the hollow
earth and andrews came to know that an
ancient legend
etched in stone about a king of the deep
something that was the eternal enemy of
the sun
as the drilling intensifies deep down in
the cave monarch begins to assess
whether the incoming storm
would affect the entrance to the hollow
earth they also wondered if gong is the
one who is unbalancing the island
despite the fact that he has always
thought
to be its protector perhaps the island
is telling them that it's time
to return kong to his rightful place and
the sooner
the better after all kong had outgrown
his surroundings and there is no amount
of food that could actually sustain a
356 foot tall thailand after all kong
can't even hide himself anywhere and
it was so easy to locate the titan on
the small island
anyway back to the story comb discovers
a cave with paintings of his ancestors
and covered in vines
at the same time brooks mulls over the
phrase of the eevee mythology
as scong enters the cave a shadow would
cover the earth he wonders if it's
forecasting the storm's arrival and if
so
how does that explain the seismic
activity
he also wonders whether the king of the
deep is an underground titan
he repeats the phrase again a darkness
will swallow the world
and the king of the deep will rise and
rise and the sun will die in his tongue
then there was a massive explosion
caused by dynamites ah near the entrance
to the vortex and this
brought out the enemy of the sun titanos
camazotz
then it was realized too late that the
king of the deep spoken off in the
prophecy was camazotz
and that the earthquakes were a result
of him trying to enter through the
hollow earth
and that the storm was what would render
the island dark and allow him to return
camazotz although powerful was like a
vampire it cannot stand sunlight
and although kamazaz barely lost the
fight against kong and was sent back to
the depths the storm never left
and skull island was rendered
uninhabitable
so the main reason as to why skull
island was in the condition it was
during godzilla vs calm
was due to the storm caused by monster
zero merging with a perpetual storm
around skull island and this was due to
camzos attracting the pacific storm
towards the island
but all this was due to monarch drilling
and trying to reach the vortex and
somehow awakened camazotz and his
minions
who had been asleep since the events of
king of the monsters when he was called
by ghidorah to hun
and so with that we come to the end of
the video do hit that like button for
support
and slap that subscribe button to be a
part of the mind kyo family
and also smash that notification bell
for regular updates
till the next one take care fam